[Wil] Bladesmiths,
check this out.
[dramatic cymbal crashes]
[imitating metal vocalist]
Forged in Fire!
I can't carry a tune
in a bucket with a lid on it
but I can tell you that here in
this first round of competition
you will use this set
of heavy metal band equipment
and combine that with
another heavy metal.
There's a cloth on top
of your anvils.
Go ahead and lift that up.
[dramatic music playing]
That is W1 round stock
that you will have to combine
using a san mai technique
with the mild steel
from these instruments
to forge a signature blade
in your signature style
with a through tang.
Good luck, Bladesmiths.
Your time starts...
Three, two, one... now!
[heavy rock music playing]
Out here on the Forge floor,
these guys are raging
against the machines
as they try to complete
san mai billets.
[Jerry] First thing I grab
is some cymbals.
Brass won't forge well
with hard metals.
Looks like Jerry's going to use
the brass cymbal.
[David] No.
Oh my God, he's got the cymbal.
That's the whole thing.
Dave. [imitates cymbal crashing]
[Ben] Wait a minute. Why is
that cymbal throwing sparks?
He's cutting something off
the bottom of that.
No, no, he's cutting through
the cymbal.
The cymbal's throwing
those sparks!
[Ben] Then that cymbal
isn't brass.
[Wil] What is that cymbal
made of then?
[Ben] It's coated steel,
or something.
[Brent] I'm thinking
I need to find the biggest,
thickest pieces of steel
I can come up with.
[David] So Brent,
over on his workstation,
has the guitar stand
which is made out of a lot
of pieces of steel.
I wanna make all three pieces
match as close as I can,
thickness-wise,
so they heat evenly.
I'm rotating my mild steel
in and out of the forge
and I'm heading to the press,
and it's just playing
this game, leapfrog.
Playing leapfrog with my steel.
[Wil] Thomas is being
really meticulous
about cleaning up those
thin bits of mild steel.
[Ben] I like to see
a clean steel
but I don't like to see people
waiting an hour to clean it.
[Thomas] I'm worried if I don't
get my steel clean,
I can get a bunch of big
delamination marks.
At one point, I realized I only
need to clean up the side
that's actually going to stick
to my high carbon steel.
But it's just taking
a lot more time than I'd like.
[Wil] Look at that banana.
Brent's got a hot banana!
As I'm setting my welds,
I see my blade start to
take the infamous banana shape.
What he did was take
a big flat piece of steel
and put a little piece
of mild top and bottom.
As you flatten that all out,
the extra steel stretches
more than the other steel
and so it starts to curve
around and around.
[Brent] So I'm constantly having
to take the banana out.
I'm in that chasing-my-tail
game right now.
But I'm able to keep up
with it.
It didn't get away from me.
I could manage it.
So Tom is heading over
to the welding station,
finally.
He's trying to get
his welds set up.
[Thomas]
I realize that the piece
I tack welded onto the steel,
the side that I cleaned up
is on the outside.
And I think trying
to clean it up
is just going to take
way too much time,
so I decide to just run with it
and hope for the best
at this point.
[dramatic music playing]
[David] Oh...
That didn't look good.
Thomas's blade,
when he was just hammering it,
it looked like a whole section
just blistered.
That wouldn't surprise me
at all,
that thin material.
All you can do when something
blisters like that
is you have to cut a groove
or drill a hole or something
to allow that gas to escape.
-Okay.
-Then weld it back together.
[Thomas] I just put
a slit in it,
so we'll see if it...
if it takes.
I got this thing
forge welded together
so I go and start
getting a knife shape.
[Doug] So with
heavy metal music,
is there a slow version?
Because Jerry is moving
at a slow tempo.
That heat must have
fatigued him a lot.
[David] Jerry's more into
Pink Floyd, I think.
He didn't quite hit
the heavy metal.
[mellow jam band style rock
music playing]
[Brent] Lots of things
can go wrong in the quench.
So I wanna have enough time
left to correct any errors
or anything that might
pop up or off in the quench.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[Doug] Brent just went
for a quench
with an hour to go.
Good for him.
[scraping]
Sounds like a pretty good
file test to me.
[Wil] What's going on, Jerry?
How you feeling, man?
All right.
Are you drinking water
out there?
-Yes, sir.
-[Wil] All right.
Yep.
I think the heat's
gettin' to him.
Let's keep an eye on Jerry.
[Thomas] I forge welded
the bubble
and everything is looking good.
I heat it just to that
right perfect temperature
and, uh, go in for the quench.
I'm just trying to keep
a death grip
on that knife
so I don't drop it in there.
That's the one thing my wife
said is,
"Don't drop the knife
in the quench tank."
[dramatic rock music playing]
All right.
I didn't drop it.
Bladesmiths!
Thirty minutes!
[tense music playing]
Jerry just quenched.
I mean, he had all of those
really thin sections of cymbal
and we didn't think
that was gonna forge weld up,
and look at him go.
[Doug] Jerry upped the tempo.
Look at those sparks.
[Wil] Man,
he's really going at it.
Twenty minutes, bladesmiths.
[Ben] Jerry's taking the slowest
method to do this guard.
I mean, we have Dremel bits
over there that are very fast
and Jerry's got
a chainsaw file
and slowly connecting the holes.
Honestly, if I was
right where he was,
I'd be sweatin'.
[Jerry] I'm just getting
this guard filed out.
And...
things started going wrong.
I'm lightheaded.
They're asking if I'm okay.
-I'm not.
-[man] Okay.
Something wrong
going on with Jerry right now.
-[mumbles]
-Get Jerry a chair.
Know where you're at?
Know what's going on?
Get him off his feet,
Come on. Gotta sit down, okay?
-Jerry is not looking good.
-There we go.
[Wil] I don't think Jerry's
quitting on himself.
I think he's pushed himself
to the point
of physical
and mental exhaustion
and it's just taken its toll
right now.
[Jerry] I just realize
that the smartest thing for me
is go over and sit
on the couch
and get oxygen
and take care of myself.
[sighs]
Five, four, three, two, one.
Bladesmiths,
shut down your machines.
Drop your tools.
This second round
of competition
is over!
-Great job.
-Good job, man.
-Where's Jerry at?
-Where he at?
[Thomas] I look around
to see Jerry.
[Brent] We didn't know
if he'd finished early.
We didn't have any idea he had
to be taken off the floor.
[Wil] Bladesmiths, each of you
was to have finished
a 12- to 14-inch signature blade
with a steel guard and pommel.
Brent, looks like
you've got a solid blade there
with a nicely finished
walnut handle.
Thomas, you've also got
a complete knife
with a Micarta and steel setup
on the handle.
Jerry... unfortunately, since
you didn't finish your blade,
there will be
no testing round today.
What happened out there?
Well, I was exhausted
from the first round
and just totally dehydrated
and...
and thought, "Man,
I'm sweating.
I need to go over
and get a drink of water."
Next thing you know,
I'm going out.
[splutters] You know,
I'm not a young guy, so...
I thought I was up
for the challenge and...
I was close.
Jerry, you fought hard
through that first round,
but unfortunately,
you just
didn't finish your work.
And for that reason,
I have to ask you
to please shake our hands,
and then please leave
the Forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
[dramatic music playing]
[Jerry]
This is not easy, man.
I thought I was in shape,
you know, working out,
getting ready for this thing.
It, uh... takes a lot
of the physical,
mental ability
to do something like this.
So I may not be
the Forged in Fire champion,
but it was a great experience.